assiégée depuis des semaines
et réduite en poussière par
les bombardements russes.
Des milliers de morts
et une situation humanitaire
catastrophique.
Natalia a réussi à quitter
cette ville portuaire su
et pour lui.
- "Il ne supportait
les bombardements" et lui a dit
qu'il voulait vivre, raconte-t-
elle non sans regret, car
elle a laissé derrièsasasasasas.
Elle décrit une ville sans eau,
sans nourriture,
sans électricité.
Pour Sergiy le traumatisme
des cadavres jonchan v v ville
est encore vif."J'ai vu comments
Grad frappaient les maisons
et déct-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t.
S'ils ont réussi à partir,des e
civils y sont toujours bloqués,
sans aucune garantie des Russes
de pouvoir évacuer en sécu
JUSTIN MASSIE, codirecteur,
Science Politique, UQAM
- Ce qui est vraiment important
pour les
objectif est de faire le lien
entre le Donbass jusqu'à
la Crimée. On utilise
malheureusement des civils commr
des gains militaires, pour faire
plier l'armée ukrainienne, qui
À Irpin, Au nord-ouest de
la c
du front sont meilleurespour l't
- Un répit pour les résidents
de la ville, qui fuient
féroces des derniers jours.
Irpin aurait été
à l'envahisseur.
Mykolaiv a vu l'étau russe
se desserrer. Une victoire
ukrainynynynynynonyme d'un
changement de stratégie
militaire du Kremlin.
- La raison pour laquelle
la Russie change de stratégie
pour se conc
précisément en raison
des ukukukukukukrainiennes,
en raison de leur résistance
acharnée, en raison de leur
les chaînes d'approvisionnement.
de front, Kharkiv est pilonnée
de façon quasi quotidienne.Ce qe
où les survivants se terrent,
- À la veille d'un nouveau
chapitre de négociatio
le Président Zelensky étudie
l'exigence russe
de neutralité, mais veut
des garanties de sécurité l'Ukr.
- Il faut que d'autres
un accord de cessez-le-feu avec
les Russes, parce qu'il est to
à fait envisageable que
les Russes profitent du cessez-
trcececececececer une nouvelle
offensive. s s s s s s s s s s n
urge les pays occidentaux
de renforcer les sanctionsrerers
maintenant un embargo sur
le pétrole russe.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa